there is nothing of this world that will
really satisfy my heart there is no
amount of success there's no
soulmate there's no um you know there's
this uh
beautiful statement this in bhakti
literature that there's you know this is
how i
phrase it anyway there you know there's
a god-shaped hole a god-shaped hole in
the heart
and we'll shove anything in that hole
we're looking to shove anything to feel
connected but only god will
fit in that hole and we try to the three
main things that we really
try to put in that hole are we feel like
there is a person out there that will
make me complete
and it's been romanticized yeah and
there are people
that we connect with there's people that
we love but they're not our god
they can't be our god and we shouldn't
make them our god or
we're setting ourselves up for hell in
the future and or we're going to become
incredibly needy or they're going to be
needy it's going to be a
real dysfunctional relationship so the
person shouldn't be our god
and the next one is there's no amount of
um
there's no amount of uh financial uh
you know height you can go to that will
actually satisfy that
yourself too there's no amount of money
you can put in that god-shaped hole
and the final one is there's no um an
amount of validation
material validation you can find people
who sometimes get the most validation
and they're sometimes even more screwed
up
and i started feeling like yeah there's
nothing of this world and i remember
sitting in a yoga center once and
reading
this quote from a swami saying
you must become materially exhausted
just
to start your spiritual life you have to
like
be cynical with material success
be give up hope and i was always a very
positive person matter of fact i'd read
these books
early in my life and think oh these
yogi's they're
they're so negative about life what's
wrong with life life is good
i've got so much hope but you have to be
cynical with material
hope you can be very very um
uh you can believe in spiritual fortune
like you're there there is a spiritual
success
but material success is a dead end and
so when i saw my father
going down so hard so so sad
i started to realize yeah this is
on this material world is an unfair
place
well that's an amazing you know kind of
epiphany to have as a young person
and it's not like you were you know
living in a mansion at the top of the
hill like you were getting success
but you didn't have to hit some kind of
crazy
bottom um or you know
spend the better part of your entire
life chasing some
material need in order to have that
reckoning like i think it's a
it's it's unbelievably true that you
have to have that
existential crisis of one form or
another and to shock you out of your
you know the maya of your your your
daily existence
that can come in the form of something
disastrous or
when you've just exhausted as much you
know
chasing of material success as is
humanly possible but
at either end of that spectrum is a
reckoning that will compel you to
confront yourself in a more
meaningful way but you were able to do
it as a very young
person i think most of us in western
culture
who are you know in the biggest picture
of things we're haves
we have we we've been to the best
beaches we've been to the coolest places
we've traveled around the world
it always boils down to this whole
big deal i did it i went to the eiffel
tower big deal but what the first system
the persistence of the illusion
is so woven into the fabric of our
like it's like yeah i did that but okay
so i felt good for a minute
that faded well it must be the next
thing and
when it's not that it's the next thing
because i got to keep up with this guy
and that's why most spend their entire
life chasing that
yeah we're trying to get some material
bucket list which it really boils down
to
big deal there's here i am it's perfect
big deal now what or this is another
great one now what now what
and i think when you get to that point
or like yeah now what
then it makes you realize okay life
isn't about trying to put your foot on
every continent on every like perfectly
caribbean caribbean beach and it's about
what is my offering in this world i had
such a great day with greg today
what is my offering in this world and
when i see people like yourself
people are just connected like okay
we're here for a short amount of time
what am i here to give and that's when
life i feel like
really becomes successful and you feel
very fortunate and very connected
and you enjoy waking up in the morning
and there's no oh crap it's monday or
friday thank god it's friday we're like
i feel like i could do what i do 24 7.
i have one i'm one of these very like
hyper i could i could do what i do
every day and for hours a day and i love
what i do
and i just feel like
we have it's important to to shine light
on the romance of uh what what hollywood
creates
or what even just people's personal maya
creates in their mind like well if i was
in this situation i'd be better off if i
lived out here i'd be better off if i
if i could only find some time away i
that that
getting fame at an early age and even
though it wasn't huge fame
getting that fame it punctured the
romance
of what a lot of people it's it's a long
long
attractive dead end
[Music]
you